discussion that Hillary Clinton had in
India earlier this week has gotten a lot
of attention she is still explaining the
reasons for why she lost and she
enumerates it this way let's listen his
whole campaign make America great again
was looking backwards you know you
didn't like black people getting rights
you don't like women you know getting
jobs you don't want you know see that
Indian Americans succeeding more than
you are remarkable and she is a delight
I mean she's absolutely delight I mean
the wonderful thing about Hillary
Clinton is she is number one the worst
candidate in American history bar none
and she demonstrates that every day
she's blaming everybody but herself for
an election loss that was entirely her
fault I mean this is the most winnable
election of all time for Democrats and
somehow they blow it because Hillary
Clinton is doing exactly this right
she's blaming half the American
population and suggesting that bunch of
rubes who have to still go to bathroom
in the outhouse and that they hate brown
people and by the way they're only two
states in the United States that have
had Indian American governors and both
of those states are red states that
voted for Donald from South Louisiana
right nikki Haley is sitting in the UN
right now as ambassador from the United
States an Indian American woman in the
Trump administration so I'm waiting to
hear her actual argument again as
opposed to everybody who voted for me a
vote against me is terrible and
everybody who voted for me is therefore
virtuous by the way that wasn't Moore's
argument you made the worst argument
made is that white women who are married
voted against her because their husbands
were gonna bully them or bring home the
whooping stick until March that you
better get out there and vote you've
been getting a lot of messages I've been
getting a lot of messages about that one
because we played OSI Jennifer cursed
tweeted this I voted for him because I
believed in him I knew he was our
country's last best hope I have three
children and I knew we were headed in
the right and my husband lost faith in
him before the election and didn't
believe he could win I'm the one who
said watch and I was right I have you
know probably 50 messages like that in
my Twitter account them again for all of
the feminists out there who say that
women are fully capable of making
autonomous decisions I asked you why are
you not condemning Hillary Clinton today
for suggesting the married women are not
capable of making those on
decisions by the way statistically
speaking none of this makes sense the
reality is the reason why married people
tend to vote Republican more often than
not marry people is because married
people are a self-selected group who
tend to be more conservative and tends
to be more religious number one and
number two marriage does change you
because now you have started thinking
about kids you have to start think about
how much money you want to save on taxes
you have to start think about where you
send your kids to school and it is true
that marriage changes voting for both
sexes in fact in the 2016 election cycle
what you see is that unmarried men voted
by plurality for Hillary Clinton it was
married men who voted overwhelmingly for
Donald Trump and the same thing is true
for unmarried women they voted
overwhelmingly for Hillary Clinton and
married women not just white married
women married women overall voted much
more close to parity in terms of Trump
and Hillary there's about a 14 point
shift on marriage you know between
Democrat and Republican for women and
about an 11 point shift after marriage
format saying it holds true for both
sexes pants thank you always good to see
you ben shapiro extra big shot